today's questions from Heather in
Florida what is your view on pet
insurance I own a dog who is an
expensive breed that's known to have
health problems however I've had him for
almost a year he's no had no hereditary
illnesses I'm paying eighty dollars a
month for accident illness and wellness
if I drop down to just accident it's $25
a month I'm on baby step two and I don't
want to get stuck with an unexpected vet
bill either what are your thoughts on
Americans last year spent seventy
billion dollars on our pets I love my
dogs they've got they're part of our
family we talk baby talk to them they
roll over and wiggle their little tails
and I've got grand dogs all three of my
kids have dogs I love animals I love
dogs
not much of a cat person but I like dogs
they are dogs as much as I love them
unless you're a multi-millionaire you
don't spend $10,000 on a dog and I love
them and just shut up you can send me
all that mail you wanna send me but
we've gotten so confused because we act
like they're people they're not people
they're an animal my wife grew up on the
farm where they ate the animals that
they raised and so her attachment to
animals emotionally is nowhere near like
mine I'm a big blubbering idiot every
time I have to put one on the sleep or
something over the years and she's just
looking at me like I'm a wuss because
when you're on the farm animals die
every day you eat them they die there's
accidents that's just farm life and you
you become attached to animals but you
have a little bit of different emotional
understanding
that they're actually animals so all of
that to say you have an emergency fund
you have an income and you cover your
your needs for luxuries which are pets
out of your savings and out of your
income I do not endorse nor do I like
pet insurance if you cannot afford to
pay for the vet bills for your dog you
should not get a dog or cat you should
not get a cat you're not ready to raise
one yet you don't have the money and so
in your case Heather you've already got
the dog you have a thousand dollars in
the bank you have your income you baby
step ones a thousand dollars if your
dogs repairs or more than a thousand
dollars you've got to think about this
dog in your situation now if you're
worth 20 million dollars and your dog
needs five thousand dollars and you want
to spend that on them that's fine but
it's a dog so now I wouldn't carry pet
insurance and I'd have my thousand
dollar emergency fund and after that I'd
have to make hard decisions and look at
what's going on in the real situation
here and figure out a way to cover with
other income or whatever but and I'm not
heartless and I'm not some me know guy
that doesn't understand I understand but
I also understand some of you people out
there for lost your freaking minds on
the way you treat this subject you're
just dumber than a rock you're out of
control and it's it's totally emotional
and you think I'm an old meanie or
something and I'm some kind of old
grouch or something I'm not I just grew
up in a generation where we understand
that animals are different than people
they are and I you know I'm on my 10th
dog and I'm that I'm that old so that
I've seen them come and go and I'm not
on my 10th kid I only got three of them
and they all three made it okay so I
mean it's a different kind of thing
there it's a different situation taking
care of your kids is a completely
different discussion
taking care of your dogs or it should be
so that sounds awfully rough and awfully
mean to some of you people and I'm fine
just troll the crap out of me on twitter
I'll be okay with it
I can deal with your hate it's alright
because you're crazy so it's fine but
that that's why I look at I love our
animals and we will invest a reasonable
amount into them based on our income and
net worth and even just based on common
sense - I got to tell you I can I could
pay a hundred thousand dollars to have a
dog fix there's not chance I'm going to
not chance I'm spending a hundred grand
on a dog not a chance and I got that
money I can do that wouldn't wouldn't
affect my future at all well you're just
mean you don't have a heart no it's a
dog I mean it's not I'm not crazy
that's what it comes down to so
hopefully that helps you
end of soapbox